here are the five levels of leadership
1 the position at the basic level of leadership
people follow you because you are the company manager
action you are really interested in your team to succeed
10 of the relationships 2
the relationship with your employees divides you
as a manager
and live on the same goals as you
action communicates the strategy
and the vision of the organization
clarifies and focuses the team on the tasks that bring in
develop a habit of sharing your own results
three the result
your collaborators admire you for your achievements
and respect your tone
they are proud to work with you
your team is your most valuable asset
focus on team development
detect your responsibilities
a small circle that will complete your leadership
4 loyalty
your collaborators
follow you because of what you have done for them
Action focuses your leadership efforts on 20
of your collaborators
expose your leaders
keys to growth experiences
change the life of your team 5
respect
the last level of leadership stands by its aura
his personality
his reputation
its impact your employees
follow you because they respect you
they are ready to sacrifice themselves for you
action form your circle of leaders to pass
their leadership at the
4 tell me
in comment
at what level of leadership you stand